in an era of endless video game
adaptations comes the true story of one
of the world's best-selling video games
Apple's Tetris takes us on a wild
journey following the guy who played
Elton John into the depths of Soviet
Russia so when this video we'll be
separating fact from fiction and
comparing the movie and its characters
to what really happened so grab some
vodka and let me blow your cartridge
because this is one Wild Ride meet Hank
Rogers the owner of bulletproof software
who discovered Tetris at the 1988 Winter
consumer electronics Expo in Las Vegas
Nevada after playing he was immediately
hooked and was put in contact with its
exhibitor Britain's Maxwell
Communications this is where Robert
Maxwell comes in the company's founder
and chairman who also happens to be the
father of Infamous child abuser Elaine
Maxwell so basically a family of
upstanding citizens you'll notice some
of the characters including Russian
leader Mikhail Gorbachev refer to him as
a politician that's because Robert
Maxwell was a member of British
Parliament from 1964 to 1970. some of
the more confusing aspects of the tetris
movie is who owned the rights to the
game what those rights entail and how
all this worked during the backdrop of
the Cold War the game was created by
Alexi pagetnov in 1984 when he was
working at the Soviet Academy of Science
in Moscow during this time with rare
exceptions intellectual property was
owned by the state and not the
individual so the rights for the game
were transferred to a state-run
organization called electroneg Technica
or elorg for short this was the
organization responsible for managing
computer software exports from the
Soviet Union in comes Robert Stein think
of this guy like a video game leech he'd
travel all over the USSR looking for
good games purchased the rights from
e-lorg and then resell those rights to
Distributors across the globe now when
you buy these rates you can choose to
purchase them for a specific platform
such as a computer an arcade or a
console like the ne yes where things get
hairy is the introduction of the Game
Boy which under the wording of elorg's
contract with Mr Stein doesn't
technically qualify as a PC console or
arcade it's in its own category called
handheld which we'll get into it a bit
second Mr Stein greatly misinterpreted
elorg's contract thinking that his right
to distribute Tetris on quote different
types of computers included home
consoles so elor gives a 10-year
worldwide PC Tetris license to Robert
Stein who then sub-licenses it to
mirosoft run by Kevin and Robert Maxwell
mirosov then sub-licenses that to Atari
for U.S distribution and Hank Rogers for
Japanese distribution so you can already
see how things are starting to get
confusing but when Hank goes to e-lorg
showing off a copy of a Japanese console
version of Tetris director Nikolai
bellikov is perplexed e-lorg never gave
anyone the tetris rights to consoles
only PC and arcade this goes back to Mr
Stein's misinterpretation of their
contract and later Stein will sign an
amended agreement clarifying that
consoles such as famicom and NES are
different from PCS so in the late 1980s
when Hank was selling Tetris on famicoms
in Japan they too were technically
illegal copies but there was a bigger
problem initial sales of Tetris in Japan
were weak at best so Hank goes to
president of Nintendo Hiroshi Yamauchi
to see if they can be of any help Hank
and Hiroshi knew each other after
Nintendo helped developed his Go video
game the same game we see him trying to
Hawk at the beginning of the movie
because of their history Hiroshi gives
Tetris to a game designer by the name of
Shigeru Miyamoto yes the Shigeru
Miyamoto the creator of Mario and Zelda
Shigeru loved the game so much and
Nintendo ends up releasing Tetris on the
famicom in 1988 where it quickly becomes
the console's best-selling game of all
time now here is where things get even
more crazy Hank is invited to meet
menorah arakawa the president of
Nintendo America and get a glimpse of
their new Game Boy handheld console at
the time Nintendo wasn't sure which game
they should package with Game Boy and it
was actually Hank who suggested Tetris
even the line from the movie where he
says if you include Mario the game boy
will be for little boys but if you
include Tetris the game will be for
everybody is said to be almost word for
word Hank goes to Mr Stein to obtain the
worldwide hand-held rights but soon
finds out that Stein doesn't have them
resulting in and yes this is true Hank
Kevin Maxwell and Mr Stein descending
upon Moscow all at the same time to sort
this Fiasco out a fiasco which has
millions at stake now Hank Did hire a
translator and against protocol went to
e-lorg to ask for a meeting and only got
one because belikov was curious in
having another bidder would only sweeten
the pot unlike the movie however was
this translator Sasha who was a KGB spy
that never happened nor his wife akemi
being threatened at their office in
Japan all of that was added for extra
drama while the movie suggests belakov
was roughed up by the KGB all we really
know is that he was closely kept an eye
on by Soviet authorities and even had
his files reviewed Gorbachev did keep an
eye on bellikov's negotiations but as
the film lays out the General Secretary
of the Communist party was too busy
keeping his country together to worry
about the sale of a video game now the
film highly dramatizes this Race Against
Time as the various parties fight to
gain their rights but in reality it was
a far more civil matter eorg chose the
company that was willing to pay the most
and yes Kevin Maxwell tried to offer
them encyclopedias in exchange for the
game thinking the Russians weren't
interested in money but rather an
exchange of intellectual properties alas
there was no KGB officer by the name of
Valentin trifanov who attempted to
extort Robert Maxwell in exchange for
the tetris rights rather his character
is more a metaphor for the greed and
Corruption that bloated the Soviet Union
at the time so not only did Hank Rogers
leave the USSR with the handheld rights
for Nintendo but because of the
misunderstanding over the definition of
what a computer is he also got Nintendo
the console rights which led to a legal
dispute with Atari who at the time was
publishing Tetris on their consoles this
would later be resolved in court in
Nintendo's favor the film also depicts a
budding friendship between Hank and
tetris's Creator Alexi which is true to
real life the two hung out and Alexa
even took him out drinking and gave him
a tour of Moscow for 13 years after its
creation Alexi didn't receive a cent for
his work on Tetris it was only until
elorg became a private company and the
Tetris race expired that Hank and Alexi
joined together to buy 50 of the tetris
rights with Nikolai bellikov purchasing
the other 50 then 10 years later in 2005
belakov would sell his half giving Hank
and Alexi full ownership of the game the
film also shows Alexi and his family
moving to America which is true Hank
helped Alexi immigrate to Seattle in
1991 where he later founded his own
software company called animatek a happy
ending however cannot be said for all
our characters Robert Maxwell while on
trial for stealing hundreds of millions
from his company's Pension funds
mysteriously died after urinating off
the side of his yacht falling into the
water experiencing a heart attack and
drowning although some have speculated
this could have been suicide or he was
offed by International assassins as
stated in the film Hank stutter Maya who
we see throughout the story became CEO
of Tetris company while Hank has focused
much of his time on several community
and sustainability oriented
organizations so while Tetris may not be
a hundred percent true to life for a
story that mostly deals with contracts
it found a way to be pretty entertaining
I hope you enjoyed this video and will
consider liking and subscribing let me
know what you thought of Tetris in the
comments below for more bad takes you
can follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
it's called The Game Boy